you
[Music]
so yeah I'm here to talk to you about a
package called a parsnip that's been
quite a long time in the making before I
get started uh why is this called
parsnip so either this other package
called carrot see a ret and I was joking
with some people my group that the first
like artstudio package I should make
when I do when the company should be
carried like the vegetable so then you
know he would be like I have a problem
of carrot that be like what was a carrot
was a carrot and then you know okay and
then somebody would have been having was
like oh you know Parsons a white carrot
so we kind of felt like you know that's
a good code name for the project and
then we just kept calling it parsnip so
it's personality so you know Alex stole
like one of my slides that's cool so uh
but you know I've been kind of like
talking about this for like forever
like what for me at least is frustrating
with ARC or packages for modeling and
it's almost always just it's never like
the numerix usually it's it's about the
the user interface right and the problem
that Alex talked about is you know that
struggle is real and that you know you
start using our package you see our pack
you're like oh I really want to try that
out and then when you start using it
you're like oh no and so you know
sometimes same people inadvertently
maybe because they don't know anything
about our make the package very
difficult to use so for example I was
looking at one the other day which I
tweeted about and got really angry about
expected your your predictor data not to
come in as a data frame but as a matrix
and that by itself is not like a deal
breaker but instead of having factors or
dummy variables for your qualitative
predictors they wanted to convert it to
a zero-based integers right so that's
the most uh Nora way of doing things and
so you know I was like no I'm not gonna
do that but you know there's a lot of
and we do have some sort of like loose
conventions and are about what you know
your modeling package should look like
but you don't have to follow them and
they're not to be honest with you all
that specific so as another example you
know we have usually have the formula
method for
and then we have like the nonpolar meth
non-formula method where you use like x
and y's or arguments and so you can
never really know when you start using a
new package whether you have either of
those or both right so that can be kind
of frustrating one really really
frustrating thing so sometimes you get a
prediction back and I love the Ranger
package but the predictions that you get
out of the prick method aren't actually
data frames they're like a specialized
Ranger object which then you have to
extract the piece out that you actually
want and then I'll talk about glib net a
little bit more but that's another good
example where like you're fitting if
you're getting classification models you
could get like for a prediction you can
get a vector a matrix or a
multi-dimensional array back depending
on the data and that's very frustrating
the program with so so the point is that
you know if you're going from model to
model and trying different things you
know you could get really frustrated and
then here's the the same thing that Alex
showed where you know just the variation
in type equal is substantial so we want
to solve that we want to you know I
don't want to have to worry about
remembering all this stuff for all the
special cases when I go to do modeling
and so I tried solving that or I did
kind of solve that with carrot
previously so carrot is like unified
interface to models and that was written
in like 2005 I think so but that's like
2005 code and that works pretty well but
there's some is definitely not tidy
right it's like the most untidy package
and so what I wanted to do is sort of
reinvent this sort of like model
interface knowing all the things that I
know now after implementing it for like
250 like models so parsnip is sort of
that part of carrot where we're looking
at like a unified interface it's really
consist with a tiny verse and does some
things differently that I've learned to
appreciate over time alright so one
thing we do in in parsnip is you know
it's this unified interface but we
decided to organize the models a little
bit differently than before so what we
do is we say you know what kind of model
generally speaking you're trying to fit
so are you trying to fit like Keener's
neighbor model or in a forest or
logistic regression or let's say linear
regression
right so let's define what the type of
model is as opposed to using LM or good
net or what have you
and so once we have a specification for
the model what we can do is we can then
generalize how to fit them right so if I
say this is on the next slide I think if
I say say I'm going to fit a linear
regression that usually means like
slopes and intercepts right and there
are a variety of different ways you can
estimate that so in percent what we do
is we sort of organize all these models
and their interfaces by what you're
trying to do as opposed the way you
wouldn't try to do it it has a tidy
interface so it's really consistent the
pipe and all the other tiny model of
packages that we have and also and this
is a really big deal very much like
broom we spend a lot of time defining
what we think a predictable interface
would be predictable in the sense that
like okay if I do predictions on an
object do I know what I'm gonna get
before I get it
in many are packages you don't know that
so we spend a lot of time trying to come
up with like you know convention or a
guideline publicly so we published all
the stuff and one feedback as to like
what does return values should look like
if you're gonna get them so if you want
to you can follow I'm not gonna click on
that but you can follow this modeling
package guideline which you know we
started right and some of its specific
the teddy bear stuff in other parts of
it are specific to just general modding
modeling ideas and you can see what we
we our decisions were there but you know
it's not like completely written in
stone so if you do have opinions we'd
love to hear them so you can file a get
issue and we can discuss them there's a
one post about blog or about parsnip on
the teddy bears blog we have another one
sort of queued up after the conference
that's more about the inner workings of
parsnip and how it does what it does the
way it does it so you know one thing
about ggplot2 and recipes is they kind
of defer evaluation of things so for
example like if you create your ggplot
code and then if you don't assign that
ggplot to an object and you hit enter
what you're doing is you're invoking
whether you know it or not like the
print function on that object so ggplot
actually doesn't do anything really
until you explicitly like printed
whether you use the
command if you save its you like an
object and do print that's when all the
the stuff happens with Gigi plus there's
drawing stuff I'm doing stuff right and
the same thing with with recipes is you
define a recipe but you don't really do
anything until you need to prepare or
reuse the recipe right so once we start
deferring the evaluation of what we want
to do it opens up a lot of doors to make
maybe the workflow a little more
sensible so the way so let's say let's
say you have some data let's say you
have I don't know some data on cars and
they're maybe they're miles per gallon
and maybe there's like I don't know
let's just say 32 data points in the
data set so you know as an example
hypothetical example so we have a like a
meta package called tidy models and you
can load that and you'll get deep liar
and ggplot and parsnip and some other
stuff so you know what we could do is
let's say we want to we want to fit a
penalized regression model like Ridge
regression you know if you're used to
neural nets this is like a way to K
model but we use like l2 penalty for the
statisticians in the audience you know
in what we'll say is like we want to fit
a linear regression and then we have a
little bit of details about the the
specific specifics of that and let's say
we kind of know like what the penalty
should be like really you know fairly
low value of like 0.01 so what we can do
is we can find a specification for that
model using this linear underbar reg and
say the penalty should be this and if we
print it out you know it doesn't really
have much detail because we haven't
specified much detail and a lot of times
the detail comes in terms of like how
are we going to fit this regression so
at least in parsnip I mean as we speak
we could fit that using LM or glim gnat
or spark or Stan or Kira's right and
that's just once we've implemented so
what we did is we kind of decoupled you
know the estimation procedure and the
package that used to to accomplish that
from the actual specification model all
right so you'll see for example if you
want to use glib net we can pipe in the
what we call the computational engine
and again the computational engine is
sort of a mashing together of the type
of estimator like is it least squares or
is it using Bayes
using like you know Karis with the the
model package that we would probably use
okay so you know the the engine might be
like LM or gloom net or Kira's or Stan
and that kind of thing and also one
other thing about the engines is they
don't have to be in are right I mean
with reticulate and all this other stuff
you know we know how to like farm an ore
has always been really good at this form
out the computations to a different
language or platform or something like
that
so again if we're not doing like
immediate execution of these things that
allows us to set up all the things we
need to do to get more general results
back so let's say we start with that
regression model specification and we
say we want to fit glim then you don't
really ever need to use this function
but I wrote this function called
translate and what that does is say well
okay you said you wanted to fit this
kind of model now that you're saying you
want to use it with glim that like how
would that actually work and what
translate does is it prints out like a a
template or a shell of what that code
would look like so if you look down here
you can see okay we're using the glint
function within the package
we don't know what x and y are and i
should also say that limit only has x
and y so if your data has dummy
variables or you know you start off with
a data frame then you've got to do the
work of you know creating your indicator
variables converting it to a matrix and
all that stuff to get little bit to work
so the underlying code would use that XY
interface for glim that lambda is the
penalty function for that particular
function and then since we know we're
doing linear regression and
automatically sets the family to
regression right so this is like the the
template of what it's going to use for
code when it translates the model
specification do the underlying engine
code that's going to be used and you
know we don't you know especially
Clement we don't usually need the the
data to make that specification right so
up to now I haven't used any data right
this could be on empty cars it could be
on let's see there's only two datasets
there's empty cars in Boston housing
right so right so you know at this point
I haven't said anything about the data
and I'll show you a counter example of
that in a minute
but once we have our data we can
actually fit a model to this
specification and so you can use the fit
function to you know you know you give
it a formula and the data set and it
goes out and fit your cologne net model
or if you if you do want to use the
formula method because that's more
convenient for you even though glim net
doesn't have that you know parsnip will
do the same thing that care and other
people do is they say okay we'll do that
work to generate all the dummy variables
and track all that stuff that we need to
and keep those pre processing objects
and then it'll fit the actual bloom net
model and have everything it needs
encapsulated into that portion of object
to make predictions and stuff in the
future right so you can use fit for the
for the formula method and then fit XY
if you just want to give it X&Y alright
so when we do prediction for example I
shouldn't dog lemon too much but I mean
it is very frustrating that you get very
different data types under different
situations so if you're just working
with like one data set you might not
notice this but if you do any
programming with bloom net there's like
a ton of like if-then statements like
you know if the number of levels my
outcome is three then I have to do this
versus one I do that and so what we what
we have is this you know this idea that
you ought to get a very formally
formally defined output back when you
make predictions and so for regression
at least our first approach of that is
to kind of follow what the rim did is
you're going to get a tipple back and
that Tibble is always gonna have the
same number of rows as the input data
set and I'll show you an example why
that matters in a minute but in that
table in that table for regression the
value or the column name you're always
gonna get is gonna be called dot pred
right no matter what model you use that
you know how the model works whatnot
you're always going to get a table for
regression with one column of creb so in
this case i'm fitting the model to the
first 29 rows and predicting the last
three so we get three rows back so why
would why would I make a big deal out of
this well with a lot of like common our
prediction functions what they do is
they use
omit either explicitly or silently and
so you know if I have a hundred data
points and three of those rows have
missing values and I make a prediction I
get 97 rows back and then like whoa like
now I got to figure out where the
missing three rows are I want to merge
that into a data set you know I got to
do some extra work to get there and so
you know we became very very frustrated
with that in this idea that you returned
the number of rows that you start out
with if I induce a missing value in the
first data point and fit the same model
and do the prediction I always gonna n/a
back okay so you can always just like
bind columns this to your data frame not
have to worry about is it going to match
up or not now one other thing about
gloom net which is really awesome is
glim that has this penalty parameter and
I specified it here and that's kind of
unusual thing to do with gloom net one
really cool aspect of this particular
model is it can fit using like one model
of fit it can get the entire path
through an entire spectrum of lambda
values so all the lambda values for that
model are kind of encapsulated into that
glitter net object so when I get
predictions for clim net I could say
well give me this lambda or that land or
this other one and fit it over and over
again but the smarter thing would be did
not specify lambda and basically get the
glenda object that can predict if any
lambda at once okay and that's a really
cool aspect of that model the problem
with doing that with this package though
is it gives you like a bunch of labeled
columns and you have to kind of trust
that the lambda values the penalty
values that you're predicting at
correspond to those and so you know I
the first time I looked at this like you
know it doesn't see anywhere that
they're gonna go into increasing order
or decreasing order so you know it's a
little bit it's a little bit scary to
use if you're first start using it so
since Glen net can return for the same
row multiple predictions at different
lambdas what do we do with this like you
know I start with an input of three rows
and I come out with an input you know an
output of three rows how are we going to
take care of that so what we do is we
basically produce a list column so in
this case there's 80 possible values of
lambda that it fit and when I make the
prediction instead of
using the predict method because not all
models have this feature we use another
function called multi predicts and
there's a silent lambda value or
argument here for clim that in it by
default uses all the lambdas and so what
that does is in this particular instance
there's any possible lambdas so what you
get is you get a table back for each row
and that table has two columns in 80
rows and so if I look at the first row
of that data set that table and remember
the holdout object here had its first
value had a missing data point in it and
so what it does is it basically gives
you a table with eighty missing values
for the dot pred and then all the
corresponding land is that you would
have gotten predictions for if you
hadn't had missing data maybe more
informative to look at the second one
and then you can see if we look at that
particular table the first five rows of
it you know we have our predicted values
across all the lambdas and so you know
you might say well like jeez you know I
can't reach you plot that so the good
news is like you know understand Toddie
are we'll just you know simply just make
that happen for you so that's like a
nice little feature so what we want to
do is we want to have these like define
standards so for another good example is
if you're doing like quantile regression
you might want to get predictions on
like I don't know like 10 or 15 or a
hundred different quantiles so rather
than you having a program your way
around that now you get back a table
with those values in it and you don't
have to worry about doing special things
for quantile regression it's you know
versus going net versus something else
one last thing I'll talk about is this
idea of data descriptors so you know if
you think about like Reina forests which
a lot of people have seen reinforce the
main tuning parameter something called M
try and when random forest goes to build
a tree M tries a number of randomly
selected predictors it will choose as
candidates for that split so if you say
m try equal 3 and you have 100
predictors it will choose a random 3 out
of that 100 as candidate that our
candidate variables to split on and then
it gets the next split and chooses
another 3 and there's good reason sounds
like a weird thing to do but there's a
very good reason that they do that and
it actually has a big effect upon
performance so when I said like we
usually don't need the data to specify
model that's really not true for a
random forest the
my is related to the number of columns
in the data set
so you know how would we we're starting
to think about like jeez how would you
write a specification that does involve
the data but you need something to use
the characteristics of the data so we
have this thing called data descriptors
we have these like you can see them
listed here these little functions that
can capture different aspects of the
data if not the data themselves so if I
want to know how many predictors I have
we have a little data descriptor
function that will calculate that before
and after or any dummy variables are
created okay so what you can do is you
can use these little functions in the
model specification so let's say I'm
gonna fit a random forest model and I
want to use 75% of the predictors
whether I have ten predictors or a
thousand visitors or whatnot
what you can do is you can start the
specification for random forests tell it
you know let's say you want to tell how
many trees to use and then you can say
well give me the number of predictors
before dummy variables you know find 75%
of those and make sure I get an integer
by using floor here now when you run
this like when you run this model
specification of course there's no data
here right so what it does it just saves
that expression and whether you're
fitting this model on the entire
training set or you resampling with
let's say cross-validation would be
about 90 percent of your training said
it does this calculation every time all
right so if we use translate here what
you see is the first thing you see is
reinforced substituted instead of trees
the thing you had would have had to
remember for the reinforced package is
entry and then you still see this
expression here that has not been
evaluated yet okay so when I go to
evaluate that using my data you get a
value of seven so it runs at that only
at that point and substitutes the value
in there for the data that you're
actually using when you invoke the fit
command and you can see you know we have
a one column for the number of outcomes
and then you can see that we actually
get the right value here so there's a
ton more to talk about with parsnip but
you know I'm gonna get the stink-eye
from Davis if I keep talking so you know
just a quick look at the things we're
thinking about we want to think about
how we're we're talking about models
right so sometimes how we talk about
models is related to the way the data is
structured so you know I used to do a
lot of work where I had repeated
measures on a particular experimental
unit so like if you have a database with
your customers in them you might have
multiple rows over time for your
customers or if you're in a clinical
trial you might follow patients over
time so if you have like a really simple
repeated measures experiment where you
have a single sort of like clustering
effect or random effect like patient or
customer you might want to fit some sort
of model excuse me you might fit that
using a random intercept model or you
might use like a hierarchical Bayesian
model or you might fit that using like a
correlated airball like GE so what we
could do is we could have the different
engines reflect something about the
model and the experiment design for that
model and so you can try all these
different things and they kind of in
some ways estimate models are either
identical functionally like identical or
extremely similar in in spirit and so
try different things so it does have to
be like rain of forests models sometimes
we can you know confound that with a
type of data that we're using okay so
thanks a lot appreciate coming
[Applause]
think we have time for one question
I thank you for this you know really
really exciting and very useful
development that's it's really great to
see it
I'd really like to use it in production
now in November you have 0.01 of parts
Nippon unsere on would you recommend
that we actually go towards the customer
with models built in there or how long
do we have to wait that's kind of a
tough question is three four years tops
five no more than five no I mean so okay
yeah this is a good question I mean it's
the first version we want to see what
people think about things people
encounter it's been out for a few months
we've had almost no github issues which
hopefully means people are using it
they're not finding any but the main
thing I would say about that is parsnip
in our sample and a lot of other things
are pieces of a wider puzzle and you
know two or three of those things are
not exist yet so for example like I have
here we want to integrate parsnip with
recipes and things like that so we're
gonna have I don't know if it's gonna be
called a pipeline but we're gonna have
like a pipeline object that then you can
use fit on that so I wouldn't say that
like parsnips aren't ready for primetime
I just say that well you can use it but
you'd still be lacking a lot of things
that you would get otherwise so you know
I'm hoping by the end of this time next
year let's say that you know if you were
to ask that question I'd say yeah we're
good so in my brain that's what I
anticipate the time ladder would suggest
but that's where I thank you
[Music]